all three pairs on defense for both teams were
just pouring into the game under pressure the
Stars take it away in the attack Zone work to
Harley he had space in the shot ricocheted up
it deflected up and out of play now it's frope
hint stting through Center he gets tripped up
by Marner stays with it shot saved by wall what an
effort by hon get that look away they're in right
now and it's Robertson on the right side hints
over to Ben Jamie Ben in front pelski chopping
at it he'll stay with it pressure applied by
Brody and then Ben spun around defensive Zone
draw for Dallas and they will control it Baro
hin taken away by neander so the slashing call
against Johnston back door feed and scored by
Morgan Riley the defenseman came untouched down
on the left side it's a four on four goal so
the Leafs strike first well sometimes you get
into these circumstances where you have a def a
forward back kind of in a defensive posture Joe
pavelski fell down initially and then as he's
trying to get back out into position the two
defensemen henan and then Essa Lindell Essa didn't
look around under of the corner of his eye it's
usually a forward's responsibility though when a
defenseman peels off the blue line to go to the
net fors leaves in the corner spinning loose is
duchaine across and hackin paaw mostly fann and
that'll send the Leafs the other way with numbers
left side nice he's got DOI Nice Shot saved by
Wedgewood he controlled the rebound and hung on
Matthews he gets hit by Lindell kingberg holds
in walks it to the center back for Marner he'll
drag shoot off the post but they're on a pretty
good run right now outscoring the opposition 8
to one since falling behind on Saturday night
against Tampa Bay Stars will try and Dent that
as we get an early whistle just 5 Seconds here
into the second period bro then out in front it's
Robertson saved by wall with the right leg he did
the splits and he maintained possession Joel
pavelski on the forche goes in pursue gets it
nudges it out in front of the net jordano has to
chase Robertson to the net because of that I me
he just bowled his own guy over dislodge sets up
Robertson and a reflexive and bring it in Riley
down in deep hackin PA reverses for Lindell
then comes to Matthews wraparound and out to
challenge his Wedgewood possession retained by
Toronto it's dander outer hash marks left Circle
up top for Marner Marner to Matthews in front
save made Wedgewood tovaris on the doorstep
out to the point where it's held in Marner
on the forehand broken up not clear Riley to
Matthews back for Riley left Circle shot save
made Wedgewood rebound he stopped that one too
the second bid from nander cleared by Dallas
and what an egress by the stars out of Their
Own Zone to Spring that and a terrific burst from
San marchment with it feeds it for duchaine on the
backand now forehand saved by wall and a little
bit of a delay on the whistle he had the puck
long enough great chances duchaine now taken
by nce long change in the second period he'll
get it to Center no further still tire decot out
there Duane's back in left side shot score masing
marchment it was a Title Wave of pressure and
the star cash in and tie the game survived that
Onslaught for a while but too dainty trying to
get it down try to slip a change in the stars
have been playing 3/4 ice as it's known here in
the second period basically from the top of the
circles are blueo in their own Zone they're back
on the TR again great change the point of attack
play by Duane in a perfect Smith stays upright
accelerating in taking on to varis and he leaves
it for Ben right Circle saved by wall the stars
are just pouring [Music] in they're pouring in
and tracking back I mean they they are doing to
the leaps here in the second what they did to
them there's a shot at the other end alert with
a save Wedgewood Stars fans just anticipating
something's going to go in the leaf net bang There
was marchment with it kept in by by Gregor giving
go he's shot saved by Wedgewood in his crease
controlled the rebound and hung on SC he's made
some big stops jordano Under Pressure here the
leaves are able to work it around yarro Tavaris
in with speed he's got Riley in the slot fed there
it got through on Wedgewood who made the save as
ni gets cut off by sudor marner's 26 years old
left wing side it's Robertson shot by hinan in
a terrific glove save by Walt he'll quickly look
to counter does so across the line Smith darting
in down the right side sharp angle W the save
rebound chipped just wide by Johnston Stars had
five shots in the first period they've got 15
here in the second here it's the leaes with it
shot by Marner he scores broken play and Marner
finds the puck from the near Dot and gives the
Leafs the lead back late in the second period
to get a hold of it and it allows some pretty
talented guys in Marner and Matthews in tight
hockey's quite a game isn't it neutral zone
Face Off you think you're in good stad it's just
a simple Rim in by the Toronto Maple Leafs and
on their for check the stars get spinning Tyler
San couldn't stop on the pot to get a hold of
it and it allows some pretty Talent Ed guys in
Marner and Matthews in tight Lea farman gets the
stars on the board but they Trail after two third
period underway Dallas trailing two to one they
are trailing at second intermission for the first
time this season that was it Marchman using the
body away from Marner chance and then the second
effort foxa put it just up high marchan's had a
couple of Great Looks he's got the only goal
another one and this one fired right off of
wall the Five Guys combined for 323 goals almost
1,000 Power Play points diving it's nice is the
second unit mostly out there now a shot score
berzi the redirection in the slot first Power
Play goal scored against Dallas this season it's
a huge one for the Leafs an Exquisite effort by
the youngster knce just inside the Blue Line what
a keep that was otherwise it's out Stars can rack
a little bit too many points of danger bruzi who's
a terrific ad for the Toronto Maple Leafs exactly
what they've needed gets a stick on it difficult
Puck for Scott Wedgewood to handle it goes down
and and through him H and Ro both go down Puck
off the body of Camp not cleared held in by B
for hinan R shot tip save rebound taken by the
Lea cleared to the line but not out the Stars
win another face off but they are just about out
of time tovaris with a bit at the empty net he
will score from just shy of Center rice becomes
the fourth different Leaf to tally and Toronto's
on their way to handing the Stars their first
regulation loss this season final seconds tick
off third straight game for Joseph wall since he
relieved samsonov on Saturday night in that time
he has stopped 93 of 95 shots against and that
includes an impressive 30 save win here tonight